it's always sort of bittersweet but
how are you guys feeling
what do you think we feel awful
you tell us how we feel we're angry
we're mad we're disappointed um yeah all
of the above
you know it's such a great show and
everybody every week has delivered done
brilliant dances being super
entertaining even people who aren't that
accomplishes dances but somebody's got
to go home you know i didn't want it to
be me i did want to stay longer than
this you know i i we really thought and
hoped we'd have a few more weeks
but um it wasn't meant to be so um i'm
gonna pick myself up dust myself off and
start all over again
um what has been your favorite part of
this whole journey
think about finishing tonight just can't
remember
you know what i've absolutely loved
working with gleb and i think
it's been so
i mean we hit it up straight away didn't
we you know we just we get on we get on
we have a similar sense of humor you
know we have things in common we like to
work hard we push ourselves we push each
other
um
and you know and i've gone out there and
i've done it and i've been petrified but
i've done it and i think i've done
myself proud you know i haven't done as
well as i would have liked to have done
um but you know that's life and
i you know i will take a lot away from
this a lot um
but yeah i mean overall right now it's
super raw you know i'm very disappointed
listen on the end of the day like we're
gonna wake up tomorrow we'll be like
listen it's a tv show we had a great
time we i got to dance with spice girl
melanie c
she got to be on dance with the stars as
one time life experience that where she
got foxtrot and the cha-cha and all of
the things and you know we had a great
time we're friends for life
you know moving on so
we wish
all the best to all the remaining
couples because everyone is
amazing you know everyone is doing an
amazing job everyone's trying
in my opinion season 30 is like this is
the highest standard in terms of like
the level of dance we've ever had in 30
seasons so it's amazing cast everybody's
killing it we wish we could have stayed
a little longer and do another couple of
dances and you know we wish we could
have
done the freestyle and the final and all
that it's all good you know
well i mean this week a good time
i'm trying to be gracious but as time
goes on and the adrenaline i just went
again
i mean i'll say there's definitely a
reaction online that is you know people
were definitely very shocked um by this
um obviously you also opened up this
week um and you were very vulnerable
which
personally for me i thought was very
inspiring because you are such a
performer and your icon
and so to see that even you sort of
struggle with that i mean why was it so
important to you to share that with
everybody
i think for the reasons that you've said
you know i think we live in a time where
we all present this version of ourselves
you know especially with things like
social media and we all look at other
people's lives and think oh my gosh you
know they're so together
they've got everything you know sorted
and at the end of the day you know what
i am a really strong person i've
overcome a lot of challenges in my life
i'm a mum you know i i'm a single mom um
and
i'm still vulnerable you know i'm it's a
human condition you know we are all we
are all the same we are all the dif
we're all different and we're all the
same and i think you know the world
would be a better place if we just
acknowledged that and had more
you know more honesty with each other
and more empathy for each other so um
you know i hope that that is a positive
thing i i did feel
a little bit self-conscious about the
package tonight um i understand that
shows like this
often you know really delve into
emotional things like that but i think
if it if it does strike a you know a
positive note with people
and make them feel like they're not
alone or you know feel like it's okay to
be vulnerable then i think it's worth it
a hundred percent i feel like you know
the lesson everyone's been talking about
is you know it never hurts to speak and
share you know mental health is so
important to just share how you're
feeling and i think that's exactly what
you did tonight
yeah 100 you know i have had my own
struggles with mental health and i've
spoken about it quite openly for for
quite a long time now actually you know
like over 20 years
um
and yeah i think it is it is important
it is important to do that so um
yeah i hope people can
benefit from it
well i know obviously you know like we
said we i think we all wanted you to you
know do the freestyle go to next week
but you
finished with a great dance i mean how
did that feel you looked great i mean
the iconic sandy outfit i mean
the best sandy tonight come on come on
the best song the best dance you know i
i felt amazing and i kind of yeah i i
felt like i felt a bit mean on some of
the other people because i felt like we
had the best one and then we got booted
up
the irony but never mind um yeah i mean
it was wonderful um and to get have
olivia newton john you know be so
involved in the show as well it was you
know and frankie avalon performing live
i mean it was such an amazing show you
know it's been really lovely to be a
part of it but i think i'm happy to walk
away from this dress
i've been getting quite stressed
well you did incredible i'm so sad to
see you go um but thank you so much for
taking the time to talk with me and i
hope you guys have a good rest of your
night and get some rest
you deserve it eat some food yeah
thanks thank you bye